AARON RODGERS.
JULY 6th.
IT'S THAT TIME!
>> IT'S TIME FOR -- ♪
E.J'S STAT OF THE NIGHT."
PRESENTED BY NO ONE!
>> UNSPONSORED SINCE?
>> 1989.
>> THANK YOU, DR. O'NEAL.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DISGUSTED ABOUT?
>> PHIL MICKELSON FIRED ME.
WHAT DID TOM BRADY DO TO GET ME
TO LOSE MY POSITION?
>> YOU STINK!
>> WE THE CHAMP.
YOU HAVE TO BEAT THE CHAMP.
>> YOU WANT TO GO OUT ON TOP AND
YOU DID.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU KEEP MESSING WITH ME.
I'M GOING TO SHOW UP THERE WITH
BROOKS KOEPKA.
KEEP IT UP!
>> HEY.
CHUCKSTER, ARE YOU FAMILY WITH
DANNY RUYEA?
>> NOT BY NAME.
>> SPORTS TALK RADIO IN D.C.
107.6 THE FAN.
DOES A SHOW WITH GRANT AND HE
ALSO A COMEDIAN.
HE CAN DO SOME IMPRESSIONS.
ONE, IN PARTICULAR, WHICH I
THINK YOU WILL FIND SCARY.
HAVE YOU SEEN THIS?
>> I DON'T THINK I HAVE.
>> IT WENT SUPER VIRAL.
>> HERE IS DANNY.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
ANALYSIS TO HAVE FOR BASKETBALL
THAT WAS PLAYED.
THAT'S NOT THE WHOLE GAME.
THAT IS HALF THE GAME.
THEM AND LITTLE YARD, HE DID A
STEP-BACK BUT HE STEPPED FORWARD
AND THEN HE MOVED BACK.
HE WENT BACK ABOUT 25 FEET.
THAT IS PROBABLY A TRAVEL BUT
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO CALL THAT.
MICHAEL JR. PORTER HE MADE A
BUNCH OF SHOTS.
JOE KITCHEN, HE IS TALL.
JIMMY JOE URK ICH DIDN'T FIND
NOBODY.
THAT IS SOMETHING.
A GOOD HALF OF BASKETBALL
BETWEEN PORTLAND AND CLEVELAND.
BACK TO YOU, ERNIE.
>> HEARD A LOT OF GUYS DO YOU!
I DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY HAS BEEN
BETTER THAN THAT!
>> THAT IS PRETTY GOOD RIGHT
THERE!
DANNY ROUHIER?
>> ROUTIER?
>> YOKEAVICK.
>> HE IS IN D.C.?
>> HE IS.
NEXT TIME 1 6.7 THE FAN CALLS
FOR YOU